i have two teenage boys
one is 16 and one is 13 and like most
families with multiple children they are
completely different
both are wonderful and have many great
qualities about them
however what really sets them apart is
that my older son
knows when to bite his tongue and my
younger son
not so much you see my younger son
really struggles with having a filter
especially when it comes to speaking up
and saying exactly what's on his mind
about three years ago a bunch of kids
and adults in the neighborhood had come
together to work through a big conflict
the kids were basically at war with each
other there was lots of tears
screaming shouting and i felt like we
would never get to a resolution
when we were in the height of everything
my younger son and the most
calm clear matter-of-fact tone turned to
another child and said
you know you are lying you know that's
not what happened it's time to come
clean and tell
everyone the truth the entire group
stopped
they could not argue with him they could
not dispute him
his manner of delivery was so real and
so honest
and i remember feeling really proud of
him in that moment because he had the
courage
and the confidence to speak up and that
moment started getting me thinking
why as a society have we created this
fear to speak up
especially in a group of our peers or
our co-workers wouldn't it be amazing if
you could tell your boss that that
project deadline to put out there is
completely
unreasonable and what about being able
to tell a co-worker that they're being
really difficult
now i know some of you are lucky enough
to be able to work in places that value
that kind of openness and honesty
however in my work as a leadership an
organizational coach
i have to tell you that is not the norm
i've observed hundreds of scenarios
and coached multiple people through
situations where they are afraid to
speak up
they're afraid to have those honest
conversations out in the open
especially when they're needed the most
and you probably know what i'm talking
about
you're in a meeting somebody pitches an
idea not everyone agrees
but no one says a word and then about
two seconds later somebody picks up
their cell phone and begins sending a
text message
to somebody else in the same meeting
telling them how stupid the idea is
and let's not forget the proverbial
water cooler conversations
as soon as the meeting is over they rush
over to appear or group of co-workers
probably near a water cooler and offer
all kinds of opinions about that meeting
but the problem is is that it's after
the meeting instead of during it
so i'm on a mission i want to stop the
passive aggressive texting
and start bringing the water cooler
conversations front and center
i believe when we can start to have
these types of conversations it will
change the dynamics of how we all work
together
we'll become more productive less
fearful and even happier at work
now i often get asked how do you muster
up the courage to have those kinds of
conversations
especially if you're not in a leadership
position or you work in a place that
does not value
that kind of openness and honesty and
for me
it comes down to a combination of four
things
confidence intent delivery
and always striving to seek a solution
so let me break this down for you
the first one is confidence and i know
easier said than done
however i have a little trick that i
hope will help you the next time you're
in a meeting and you want to speak up
but you're feeling a little
nervous or anxious i would recommend you
use what i call the captain obvious
strategy
it goes something like this call me
captain obvious but isn't that solution
not really going to address our problem
by saying captain obvious out loud it
basically adds a little humor to the
moment
but it also does a check of the room to
see if anybody else is hearing
seeing or feeling the same things and by
having that confidence to speak up
you then open the door to allow others
to have that same
confidence now you don't always have to
say captain obvious out loud
you can say it quietly in your head
right before you speak up
kind of like you're mentally pumping
yourself up before a big game
regardless of how you use a strategy
confidence is the first step
in all of this so let's move on to
intent
intent is about having a purpose and a
reason to speak up
intent is about knowing and
understanding that by me speaking up
i either want to work through a problem
or address a situation
for example when someone's being really
difficult in a meeting and i call them
out on it
my intent is not to embarrass them my
intent is to make them aware that their
behavior
is putting a strain on the group for my
son his intent was that the truth be
heard
he wasn't just calling the other child a
liar out of spite
well at least i don't think he was he
was only 10 at the time
so i could be wrong however
his underlying intent was that the truth
be heard so that we get to a resolution
i feel when you go in with a positive
intent it's much more likely that your
message will be received with an open
mind
all right let's move on to the third
step which is delivery
delivery is about how you frame the
actual message
delivery needs to be factual real and
when i say real i mean
no sugar coating what you're trying to
say and it must always take the
receiver's feelings into account
let me give an example let's say you're
working on a team and you know there's
an individual who just isn't pulling
their weight
everyone knows it because you basically
talk about this individual
almost every day at the water cooler but
nobody wants to bring it up in the
larger group setting
then after several weeks of grumbling
and some serious loss in productivity
you finally decide we need to have a
conversation as a larger group
so let me show you how the delivery
should look hey team
we have not met any of our commitments
over the past several weeks
simple direct no sugarcoating situation
and then you would continue hey team
member we've looked at the data and
we've realized that you have not been
able to meet your commitments over the
past three sprints
factual we have the data to show these
are our concerns and why we're having
this conversation
and now this is where we really want to
take the receivers feelings into account
we are concerned that you do not have
everything that you need and that we
need to do something better to support
you
empathetic caring and in my experience
it almost always works when we're able
to have these types of conversations out
in the open it creates the environment
so the team feels more confident to
speak up
and in my past experience some of these
teams have become some of the highest
performing teams in the company
just by being able to have those types
of conversations
imagine that now let's move on to the
last piece of this
which is always entering a conversation
with a mindset of wanting to seek a
solution
and for me that's the piece that i see
that is missing the most
how many of you have been in a meeting
and you work through a problem but you
realize you spent the entire meeting
hashing through the problem and then you
get to the end of it
and you need to schedule another meeting
just to work through solutions
yep probably happens more than we'd like
to admit let's say you're on a project
and you know it's a problem you've been
slogging through it with no end in sight
so you call somebody into the room
that's a little bit closer to the work
hoping that you can understand what the
problems really are and work through a
solution
but they come into the room and this is
what they say
this project is a disaster we do not
have the people the skills
the resources or the technology to get
this done and we're going to spend a
million more dollars before we see it to
the end
and then they leave the room so just as
an fyi
that's what i call a mic drop moment and
those moments are not productive
now i know that was an extreme example
however mic drop moments
like that happen every day at work
that's why it's so important that we
come into a conversation
with a mindset of wanting to seek a
solution
even better if you actually bring
possible solutions to the conversation
that then creates the space to start to
work through options
so if i could rewind that mic drop
moment i would hope and recommend the
conversation go a little bit more like
this
we've come to realize we don't have the
people skills resources or technology
in-house
that's why we're struggling so much on
this project i think if we were to use
this external vendor who we know
has this experience and has done this
type of work before we're going to be
able to complete it
and meet our goals there possible
solutions
create possible options
now i know some of you may be saying
this is a great concept in theory but
will
never happen or be accepted where i work
i would challenge you to change your
thinking
because there is power in speaking up
nine times out of ten if i'm thinking it
i bet at least one other person in the
room is having that same thought
and the beauty is that once it's said
that's when the real conversations start
to happen
look at my son i believe he was able to
change an entire group dynamic
just because he had the courage and the
confidence to speak up
the best organizations are full of
people at
all levels that have that same courage
to tackle
the tough topics and by being open
and honest not only are we helping
ourselves but also our organizations to
have these conversations
and those are the ones that are needed
the most call me captain obvious
but isn't that the kind of place that
you want to work in
thank you